[MUSIC - ECHOED]
Soylent is people.
It explores what's
possible when we
start embedding humans,
paid crowd workers,
into our interfaces.
Soylent is an add-in from
Microsoft Word that gets human
help to support tasks
that Word can't do well--
shortening, proofreading, and
open-ended editing via macros.
It does this by recruiting
workers on Amazon's Mechanical
Turk service to solve hard AI
problems for just a few cents.
Each member of the crowd
does a little bit of work.
So it's like having tens
or hundreds of people
help you write your document.
One of Soylent's features
is called Shortn.
Shortn helps writers
cut down their text.
It's tough to trim a document
to meet a size limit.
It takes time, and it's
hard to look objectively
at your own writing.
Shortn asks Mechanical
Turk workers
to find parts of
the document that
can be cut down without
changing your meaning,
and then offer a few rewrites.
Its interface gives
you direct control
over the length of the text.
Drag the slider to
specify the length
you want for your
paragraph, and Shortn
combines the edits to match.
We've shortened text ranging
from blogs, academic papers,
and rambling emails, and we
got cuts down to about 85%
of the input each time.
We paid workers about
$1.50 per paragraph.
You can pay less, but you'll
wait longer for workers
to pick up your task since
they're less lucrative.
We got it down to about $0.30.
Crowdproof is a distributed
human proofreading service.
Microsoft Word misses all
sorts of obvious grammar errors
that humans can catch.
Crowdproof finds these errors,
explains in plain English
what the problem is, and
offers anywhere from one
to five rewrites.
We've used Crowdproof
to clean up
text like non-native English
writing, bad Wikipedia
pages, and paragraphs full of
errors that Word can't find.
Word finds about 30% of
the errors in these texts.
Crowdproof finds
about 2/3 of them,
and fixes about 90% of
the errors it finds.
Last is The Human Macro,
a natural language
crowd scripting interface.
Usually, users would need
to translate their ideas
into code, which is tough.
Instead, The Human Macro lets
you automate complex actions
by describing what you
want naturally, in words.
Launching The Human Macro
opens a request form
where you can write what
you want like you would
a Craigslist post.
Our goal here is to keep users
from launching buggy commands.
So we show a live preview
of what the request will
look like, and let the user do
a test run on a single paragraph
or sentence.
Our users have gotten
The Human Macro
to transform a short story from
past tense to present tense,
to find Creative Commons
licensed images to describe
a paragraph, and to flesh
out citation sketches
into real references section.